so Walter I'll start with you how
successful was this launch and this
rollout in that it differed from typical
product rollouts like the iPhone over
that we really don't know how successful
it is quite yet because the company
hasn't released any numbers and that
actually in itself is not a huge
surprise they haven't been real
announcing pre-order numbers for for the
ipad for the last several models so we
don't know it was a good marketing event
for the company I mean the watch
technically sold out within a few
minutes for many of the models but again
sold out of what you don't know what the
inventory was behind that in her memo
Angela Aaron says are we going to launch
every product this way from now on no we
all love those blockbuster Apple product
launch days and there will be many more
to come JP what is the best strategy for
Apple how should they be launching these
products well for this particular
product it was important i agree with
Angela errant that they teach people
what this product is about you know
there's been a wearables market for a
couple of years now and presumably Apple
has probably just sold in about six days
more smart watches that have been sold
up until that point over a period of two
years so for them to do that they have
to really teach people why do I want
this device and what is it capable of
doing and if those early adopters don't
understand the device they'll run into
problems so it's a logical strategy and
yet Walter you say the rollout was
typical what do you mean by that is
typical in the fact that when they
launch the product you have the products
selling out as far as the pre-order is
concerned very quickly which is a
typical apple thing where you know again
we don't know what the inventory is
behind that but there are at least a
reflection that there is strong too man
i doubt that Apple you know sold out of
a couple hundred thousand watches
they're probably pre-orders that are in
the millions and again that's been
typical for Apple that you know these
products that the delivery dates get
pushed out very quickly after going on
sale JP there's always this question
whether Apple is trying to increase
demand by holding back supply or whether
indeed they just can't make enough for
everyone who wants to buy one what's
your take on what's going on with the
watch in particular
I think in this case there are some
supply chain concerns they're not easy
to verify but the tactic engine which is
the the haptic feedback the vibration
motion there have been some questions
about how quickly they could actually
get those made and also the display
that's being used on the watch was also
a concern all of that said I agree with
your other guests this is pretty typical
apple likes to see those quick sellout
dates it creates only more buzz for them
so how do you expect a man to evolve
Walter you know there are surveys out
there one survey saying eleven percent
of iphone users will be buying the watch
how will that number grow and those
surveys are based on people that have
never actually touched the wash used it
have seen their friends use it at
parties or whatever so I think these
initial surveys should be taken with a
with a level of a grain of salt that I
think you just have to see how the
product gets used out in the market I
mean keep in mind that in the US alone
which has a lot of disposable income
there's a hundred million active iphone
users globally it sits 500 million so
there's a lot of customers out there
that already have a product that this is
a natural extension of so we'll have to
see how it rolls out and also keep in
mind that look we're in the june quarter
as far as when these products are
selling if they sold let's say five
million five million watches during the
quarter that's two billion in revenue on
an estimate for that quarter that's 45
billion so this watch as far as the
numbers are concerned aren't going to
make or break it it's just a further
extension of the ecosystem and frankly
ten cooks really his first new product
category as a CEO it's interesting to
read all of the reviews the first wave
of reviews about the Apple watch there
they're cut some of them are conflicting
some of them are confused people don't
seem to know just necessarily how
they're going to be using this thing yet
JP have have you tried it out do you
have one do you want one should we want
one I have tried it on and you know the
thing that you is really noteworthy
about Apple watch is just how physical
the device it is it's not primarily just
to watch that you glance at it's
something that you can use to pay for
goods at the store with Apple pay you
can get on your airline flight using it
you can soon open the door to your hotel
room and starwood hotels so there's a
very physical aspect to it that
i think is unusual that people are not
familiar with and of course it's worn
directly on the body and that is
something that people have to get used
to having a computing device that close
to you at all times is a bit of a
learning curve Walter how about you well
what I'm hoping for is another one of
the functions will be a remote control
that cover that that controls the Apple
TV with new functionality that gives me
an alternative to the 120 dollars that
i'm paying DirecTV today and that's
something that could be another function
for the watch and and and you know kind
of a precursor to new product categories
that Apple can get into overtime I've
also tried the watch again i was when i
first tried it when it was very first
announced if I felt very glitchy the
more recent test of it it was performing
really flawlessly some of the frankly
the criticisms online have been focused
on uses of the watch like scrolling
through Twitter feeds that most users I
just don't think we'll be using the
watch for this is an extension and
there'll be there'll be ways that people
use the watch that are just not thought
about today so we're very positive on on
you know what the potential is for this
watch